[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
nuestra invitada de hoy es tirana
directora ejecutiva en funciones de
Human Rich watch nos acompaña desde
Londres Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros esta semana la organización
internacional de Derechos Humanos
publicará su informe anual tristemente
su informe sombrío
Shoes Pero antes de hablar sobre algunos
de los temas que aborda me gustaría
conocer su opinión sobre una cuestión
general la democracia parece estar en
peligro recientemente en Brasil lo
simpatizantes del presidente saliente
Jair bolsonaro asaltaron los edificios
oficiales del gobierno en Brasilia un
evento que hasta cierto punto hace eco a
lo que pasó en el capítulo en Washington
hace dos años hay más regímenes
autoritarios en lugares como Turquía
túnez e India
ha habido una ola de golpes de estado en
África occidental le preocupa que la de
los Derechos Humanos estén en un momento
muy complicado este año
creo que esos ataques no solo simbolizan
La Peligrosa fragilidad de las
instituciones democráticas que son
necesarias para respaldar los Derechos
Humanos sino que también muestran la
desesperación de los autógrafos de los
déspotas y de los hombres poderosos que
están empezando a perder poder las cosas
están cambiando y ha habido resistencias
globales frente a los gobiernos
autoritarios y frente a esa especie de
agendas en contra de los Derechos
Humanos en el caso de Brasil
convulsionaro y de Estados Unidos con
Trump ambos líderes gobernaron con una
agenda que iba muy en contra de los
derechos humanos y realmente trataron de
menoscabar las instituciones
democráticas en particular
bolsonaror
a lo largo de su presidencia trató de
socavar la independencia del poder
judicial debilitándolo constantemente lo
cual sembró dudas dentro de los sistemas
democráticos en Brasilia y llevó actual
por esa clase de actos violentos y esos
ataques físicos y a través de los medios
contra instituciones democráticas clave
son Realmente una señal de desesperación
No señalan que los déspotas y los
autócratas y pienso que lo importante es
lo que pase después y cómo se vaya a
fortalecer la democracia vimos los
ataques que ocurrieron en 2022 y 2023 es
el año de fortalecerse y alzarse es un
llamado a la acción
[Música]
sus informes ustedes examinan la
situación en Ucrania Se podría decir que
ahí se ve toda la gama de violaciones a
los Derechos Humanos
lo interesante y lo que ustedes resaltan
es que esos crímenes están siendo
monitoreados documentados e investigados
por la Corte Penal internacional por el
sistema de las Naciones Unidas incluso
por poderes judiciales de varios países
no solo en Ucrania sino en varios países
occidentales
Cómo ve la situación es optimista por
ver esa reacción o le sorprende lo que
usted y otros han documentado en el
terreno en Ucrania
la respuesta mundial a lo que está
pasando en Ucrania realmente no se ha
mostrado lo que se puede lograr cuando
los gobiernos se unen y luchan contra
los autócratas que se aferran al poder y
contra la violación generalizada de
Derechos Humanos
hemos visto a la comunidad internacional
utilizar todas las herramientas de su
Arsenal para asegurar que Habrá justicia
y rendición de cuentas para asegurar que
las violaciones a los derechos humanos
se detendrán hemos visto acciones
extraordinarias por parte de gobiernos
de todo el mundo
por parte de la Corte Penal
Internacional para que se empiece a
reunir evidencia y para asegurar que las
Cortes y los procedimientos legales
estén listos para iniciar apenas sea
posible
también hemos visto el mecanismo de la
ONU en acción el consejo de Derechos
Humanos creó un mecanismo para reunir
evidencia para futuros enjuiciamientos
se está sentando un precedente muy
alentador para el futuro y debemos
asegurar que se aplique a otros
conflictos y crisis en todo el mundo
quiero pasar ahora un país donde ha
habido otro tipo de violencia porque no
se trata de una guerra es el caso de
Irán el movimiento de protesta se ha
extendido durante varios meses y las
represiones han sido muy duras ha habido
incluso ejecuciones públicas qué opinas
sobre la situación en Irán y lo que
significa
lo que está pasando en Irán Es realmente
fuera de lo común empezó como un
movimiento de protestas por la muerte de
Max a mini liderado por mujeres y niñas
muchas personas pensaron que era una
protesta contra las leyes del y por los
derechos de las mujeres y Puede que haya
empezado así pero rápidamente se ha
convertido en una protesta de Dimensión
nacional en la que iraníes de todos los
ámbitos de la sociedad de todas las
edades de todos los géneros están
saliendo las calles para decirle al
gobierno al régimen que es suficiente
que están cansados de vivir en una
sociedad donde sus derechos son
totalmente respetados están cansados de
vivir en un país donde la gestión de las
autoridades es muy mala y donde la vida
para unir a Nick promedio es muy difícil
lo que las autoridades iraníes deberían
ver y el mensaje que deberían estar
recibiendo Es que la población no
aguantará más sus peticiones son muy
claras la represión no es un atajo para
la estabilidad Y eso es lo que los
autócratas más temen que las personas a
las que van a controlar los hagan
responsables esas protestas son un
primer paso pero también es importante
lo que haga la comunidad internacional
después de esto
hay que asegurar que le dedique su
atención política y su energía a esta
situación no hay una solución rápida se
necesita un cambio a largo plazo y la
comunidad internacional debe tener el
mismo vigor de esas protestas para
asegurar que esas peticiones se
conviertan en una realidad
me gustaría pasar ahora a China el
consejo de derechos humanos de la ONU no
logró aprobar una resolución para
debatir el reporte realizado por la alta
comisionada de la ONU para los derechos
humanos en el que se describían los
abusos en la región de chinyang y se
afirmaba que podían ser considerados
crímenes contra la humanidad sabemos que
hay mucha presión por parte de China
sobre el sistema de las Naciones Unidas
y sobre muchos países cree que esta
decisión puede cambiar por otros
factores por las tensiones entre Estados
Unidos y China y que los derechos
humanos en China puedan ser un tema
importante en el 2023 o teme que vuelva
a ser silenciado
Primero me gustaría empezar diciendo que
los derechos humanos en China son una
prioridad para el 2023 no es algo que
esté condicionado es seguro y lo es por
la gravedad de los crímenes cometidos
por el gobierno de shim contra los
fujigures en shing son tan atroces que
alcanzan el nivel de crímenes contra la
humanidad Esa es la conclusión de Human
right wash y de la oficina del alto
comisionado
en 2022 fue muy decepcionante que
fallara la resolución del Consejo de
Derechos Humanos tan solo para debatir
más a fondo del reporte escrito por la
ONU pero solo falló por dos votos Y eso
realmente es algo fuera de lo común fue
una votación muy cerrada y si se
presenta a otra resolución es una buena
oportunidad para que los miembros del
Consejo de Derechos Humanos voten de
manera distinta porque la cantidad de
evidencia sobre la gravedad de los
crímenes están siendo cometidos por el
gobierno de chi son Realmente innegables
en este punto pienso que debería haber
un cambio en el resultado de la votación
creo que en este momento hay grietas en
la armadura autocrática del gobierno
chino y la única manera de aumentar esa
grieta es asegurar que la comunidad
internacional se alce no basta con que
un solo país se alce contra un régimen
tan grande es necesario que esas nuevas
coaliciones de las que hemos hablado y
que estamos defendiendo también lo hagan
de cierta manera la cantidad genera
seguridad
última pregunta ustedes optimista ante
la reacción de la comunidad
internacional por los crímenes cometidos
en Ucrania pero desde Etiopía hasta
Afganistán entre una larga lista de
países se están cometiendo crímenes muy
serios y ocurren en silencio nadie los
está monitoreando nadie los está
señalando esto le preocupa
implementación
sí Y creo que Etiopía es un buen ejemplo
La tregua que simplemente es frágil es
bueno que se haya hecho pero gracias a
la historia sabemos que no se obtiene
estabilidad sin rendición de cuentas y
lo importante en este momento es que
haya una rendición de cuentas por los
crímenes que se han cometido la unión
africana debe tener un papel muy activo
condenando y previniendo los abusos
debemos ver que los mecanismos de
monitoreo de la unión africana
simplemente y que se permita el exceso
de la ONU a esas áreas agree por ejemplo
las autoridades le han quitado una
página al manual de los autócratas bajo
ese manual los abusos ocurren en la
oscuridad no se permite la entrada de
periodistas no se permite la entrada de
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos pero
es nuestra mantener la atención sobre
eso
ellos pueden complicarlo pero nosotros
debemos seguir haciendo presión y
asegurar que el resto de la comunidad
internacional no olvide la gravedad de
los crímenes cometidos en Etiopía porque
si esto ocurre y no se asegura la
rendición de cuentas veremos la historia
repetirse
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en la
entrevista de France 24 y gracias a
ustedes por verla
[Música]